let's again put put our sort of
philosophical hats on do you think the
us government or some other government
is in possession
of
something
of extraterrestrial origin that is far
more impressive
than anything we've seen
in the public
if i i've not seen anything personally
but if i believe the people who i don't
think can lie yes
i says how does that make you feel in
terms of the way government works the
way our human civilization works that
there might be things like that
and we're not they're not public is is
there a hopeful message for transparency
that's possible like if you were if you
were uh in power and i'm not saying
president because maybe the president is
not
the source of power here
would you release this information in
some way or form yes
if i were
i i think it would i think it's
i think it's something that can bring
humanity together
right i think that
knowledge of this kind of thing to know
that we are
you know we are more alike than we are
different
in comparison to whatever this is
is
uh
is a positive thing for us
um
and to know
you know i don't necessarily care that
the government has been hiding it and i
think you know people who've been
talking about what we should give
government officials or whatever amnesty
i think that's probably the right
the right answer we don't this isn't a
time to look back and say you did
something wrong you did whatever you did
because that was the data you had
available to you at the time and those
you had good reasons for doing it now if
your reasons were selfish
if your reasons where you wanted to do
it because you wanted to monetize it
yourself
uh
to the to your benefit but against that
of others then i think maybe there's
something else that could be said but
you know
an opportunity to get all this
information out if i were in charge
i would i would try to do it now
i might be shown something though that
says um there's a reason why you don't
want to let anybody know this
maybe you don't want everybody have
having access to unlimited uh energy
because maybe you might turn it into a
bomb
or something that
gives you hints that something like
unlimited energy is possible but you
haven't figured it out yet and if you
make it public
maybe some of the other governments you
have tensions with will figure it out
first right i mean
it's kind of an arms race going on i
think in all forms and it's it makes me
truly sad because uh it's obvious
that
for example the origins of the covid
virus
it's obvious to me that the chinese
government whatever the origins are
is interested in
not releasing information about it
because it can only be bad for the
chinese government
and every government thinks like this
like what uh every actually this has
been disappointment to me
talking to pr folks at companies
like they're always nervous
they're always like conservative right
right in the sense like well if we
release more stuff
it can only be bad and then an elon musk
character comes along who tweets
ridiculous memes
and doesn't give a [ __ ]
and i've been encouraging ceos i've been
encouraging people to be transparent and
of course government national security
is really
like another level it's human lives at
stake
but
let's start at the lighter case of just
releasing some of the awesome insides of
the how
how the sausage is made the technology
and being transparent about it because
it it excites people
it uh
like you said it it connects people
and it inspires them
it's good for the brand it's good for
everybody i i i honestly think this kind
of idea that people will steal the
information and will use it against you
is um
is an idea that's not true in this idea
of the 20th century like you said some
of the benefits of the social media
uh
our our social world is that
transparency is beneficial and i hope
governments will learn that less and of
course they're usually the last to learn
such lessons
you